here's a sign of how Auto control woke
education has gotten a New York City
heiress says she was brainwashed by her
Elite liberal college and her mother had
to pay over 300 a day to deep program
her
I was indoctrinated it's as simple as
that they told me that I had been
impressed my entire life and I didn't
even know it that there was an
underlying patriarchal bias inherent in
absolutely everything so I started to
look at the world from a lens of being a
victim you know what's interesting about
that Dana is that she was very close
with her mother she was a former
competitive figure skater who skated all
over the world
um and they didn't get her in the first
year at Mount Holyoke they didn't get
her in the second year they got her in
the third year and that's when she said
she couldn't shrug off uh what what they
were teaching I mean this is something
that happened to a very intelligent
young woman
yeah and I that's why it's gotten some
attention because you can imagine
imagine being the mom and dad and you
have this amazing daughter who is
basically best all-around at everything
that she does and a competitive figure
skater that skates around the world
that's a very seriously intelligent and
strong-willed person someone who
understands a lot of discipline who
understands routines and figure skating
yeah not that hard yeah
triple Luts we're gonna do a triple Luts
for uh Christmas are you going to be way
overrated yeah you don't even need you
don't even need to do it on ice it's so
easy okay well maybe maybe for one more
thing we could have you do that um but
this is something that happened at Mount
Holyoke is happening in other places
there's this group called Do no harm and
it's a group of doctors that is trying
to push back against what they call woke
creep in the medical field because you
have diversity and Equity issues that
are being taught all throughout medical
school but imagine you're the patient
and in a few years you go and now your
doctor has been trained in a different
way rather than just based on the sign
clients that's what they're trying to do
is to bring a little attention to that
you know Jesse what Dane is talking
about is the fact that 58 of the top 100
U.S medical schools uh have mandatory
programs in the fundamentals of critical
race theory that we've been told pretty
much doesn't exist uh it's awoken
doctrination to the doctors and they're
raising social justice as a focus is
that relevant to medical school teaching
well I don't want to be discriminated
against as a straight white male by my
physician like I said if there's a
mistake made and I undergo some radical
gender reassignment surgery because
someone has it in for me that's going to
be a problem
and if you want to save the 300 a day to
deprogram someone from being woke
watch Fox it's the cost of a basic cable
subscription it's a graded market and I
want to speak directly to the heiress
right now Dana hold my hand Oh Boy geez
women need men
and men need women we need each other
and if you understand nature you
understand there is not a war between
the sexes
we need to Make Love Not War and you
need to stop chopping your hair off and
calling us toxic we are on a mission yes
we peacock but we peacock for your
attention so fall in love and let's all
live happily ever after all right there
is something I do want to address with
her now as an heiress it's a little bit
of a sticky situation because in a way
you're almost like a very successful
wealthy man and you don't know if
someone's falling in love with you for
your money or for your heart so I would
advise her you can fall in love but sign
up prenup wow professors encouraged
alienation from the parents and offer
their homes to stay and if they didn't
the kids were ostracized I mean this
kind of pressure what did the professors
get out of it Harold I'm going to give
300 for Jesse to give you a
programming
look I I pray for that that young lady
in her family uh whatever it needs to
have happened I hope they have happened
and I I my kids are aging seven I hope
they don't have to be deprogrammed I
hope I hope I'm able to get what they
need at home alone with what they need
at school okay
do we do we know the name of the D
programmer
I keep looking at this I didn't read the
article I couldn't find you didn't I
read the whole thing it's a four day
weekend you think I'm going to sit
around and read articles I don't want to
be here I want to be in bed everybody
likes to Brand the other side as a cult
right during the Obama said cult just
let me finish
we know whenever everybody was talking
about Obama was a cult and people said
the Trump's occult this is different
because there's not a head of this this
actually is an ideology that provides
one solution to all your problems and
that solution is always you were either
a victim or you're a victimizer the
problem with this it's hard to deprogram
somebody when it's all over a culture
and that it opens doors for you that's
that's the problem College it used to it
used to just be College was the
brainwashing Enterprise especially when
there's only one perspective being being
offered and you have these rituals and
the ideologies
um but it's now spreading into as you
the health industry medicine you HR
you're gonna I mean where did gender
affirmation surgery come from right that
didn't come from doctors so the it this
is this is in a way it is a cult but
it's a tough one to beat because it's
now kind of like gotten out of our
control that's all